y 280 congresistas integran las dos
cámaras del legislativo colombiano todos
como si de un regalo de navidad se
tratara recibieron el 24 de diciembre
mediante este decreto presidencial el
monto de su aumento salarial para 2020
una subida del 5 12 por ciento de
carácter retroactivo este salario de los
parlamentarios pasa así de 9.300 de 73
dólares a 9 mil 853 dólares mensuales en
un país con un salario mínimo que para
2021 pasará de 280 a 290 dólares
este mensaje es nefasto y además ayuda
muchísimo a esa de legitimación y esa
desconfianza que ya de por sí la
ciudadanía tiene del congreso de la
república en los partidos de gobierno
los partidos tradicionales en colombia
nunca nos han permitido que se aprueben
leyes que permitan reducir el salario y
que estemos muchísimo más acorde a
sintonía contra con la ciudadanía
desde el ejecutivo explican que este
aumento es una obligación constitucional
y sostienen que él
ha sido inferior al de años anteriores y
después de haberlo analizado si se
podría recortar o se podría aplazar nos
dimos cuenta que la ley nos obligaba a
tener esos reajustes y por eso se se
expidió el decreto que como ustedes lo
decían muy bien es un decreto que se
expide para el año 2020 cuando los
funcionarios y el salario mínimo en
colombia creció un 6% al congreso se
inició una reducción y tiene un
incremento del 5.1 por ciento no es la
primera vez que el suelo de los
congresistas se convierte en un debate
público hace dos años el país acudió a
las urnas en una consulta contra la
corrupción que entre sus medidas incluía
una reducción del salario de los
legisladores sin embargo el referendo no
consiguió el mínimo de participación
exigido por la ley